how' your dad react to meeting the first
guy you brought home to meet him this is
a good one
so how is Pierce off camera how has the
family adjusted to the move what's your
skin care regimen breast xplant piece of
advice you'd give your younger self what
would you do if you found out your
husband was sleeping with a trans
woman please talk about how you keep
your face so beautiful of course staks
but also fillers question mark here's
one I'm social my girlfriend is not we
generally stay in and I'd like to go out
more how do I do this best and worst
thing about being newly
married hey guys long time no talk I'm
back I did a podcast with my dad a
couple weeks ago it came out last week
and I figured before I started
podcasting again I would do a Q&A
because I Disappeared for kind of 6
months kind of it wasn't terrible but
basically what happened was I moved from
Canada to
Nashville last when was it it would have
been
2021 and I started not feeling great in
Nashville and I thought it was tree
allergies and I started getting insomnia
and heart palpitations and general
weakness and fatigue and my joint
started hurting kind of in an arthritic
way and my skin was breaking out out and
my stomach was upset it took quite a
while to figure out whether or not I was
just sick because we moved there and I
got strep throat that wasn't treatable
with antibiotics for about 3 months and
it just kept going up and down and up
and down that turned into pneumonia
anyway figured it was the tree allergies
cuz Nashville is in kind of a bow and
I'm extremely allergic to trees like FG
on anaphylaxis if I really get covered
in pollen and so we moved from Nashville
I thought that was a terrible decision
we moved to Miami which which can be
better Florida can be better for people
with tree allergies certain areas and
then I moved to Florida and things were
okay and in November last year I moved
into a house that my parents had
purchased and then just got over the
next four months got sicker and sicker
and sicker and in about January so last
January
2023 I was lying on the couch and I
thought okay this is abnormal this isn't
just cold that Scarlet's bringing home
like I don't even have enough energy to
like raise my arms I was waking up in
the morning with mucus like a toddler's
level of mucus and it occurred to me
February that I was reacting to mold in
the house and the house was basically
new it was from 2018 this gorgeous
Waterfront house and it turned out there
was mold in the H VX and that the roof
hadn't been sealed properly so there was
mold in the drywall that you couldn't
see thank God I figured it out
eventually and I clued in because there
was one area by the front door or the
back door that um I actually could
eventually see mold coming out from
behind the drywall so we left I stopped
podcasting then I actually took a break
from work which I never do uh because I
couldn't think anymore I I had no
internal dialog serious brain fog a
whole bunch of autoimmune symptoms I'd
cut out Sal for my diet because I was
only eating lamb and salt at that point
and I was
like I've solved all my other problems
by using diet so maybe I'm suddenly
reacting to Salt which is ridiculous
really but um we figured out it was mold
I moved out I took a break from work for
two weeks till I got my internal
dialogue back and could actually focus
and write
emails and 6 months we spent in hotels
because we had to renovate the Miami
house house in very dramatic ways uh and
we're selling it now because we've moved
out of Florida but we didn't want to
poison the next people who moved in so
we had to remediate it first which I
think most people would just lie and not
do but we got so sick Scarlet was sick
my husband Jordan was sick and so I
paused the podcast because I really
wanted to focus on the work that I have
to do um and I could barely do that so
that's where I went for 6 months and we
went from like hotel to hotel first we
went to Arizona to do mold treatment to
try to get better uh and the mold
treatment that I'm currently doing it's
for uh chronic inflammatory response
syndrome it's called sers and I think it
makes sense that the reason I'm allergic
to everything is from mold exposure
throughout my life because when I was
little when I was about eight I don't
really know what happened before that
age but I know that when I was eight we
had a massive leak in our basement which
is where I was living and there was
black mold all over the basement and I
got just sicker and sicker and sicker
and sicker eventually managed to put
most of those symptoms into remission
with the LI diet and the lion diet
worked for a long time and then over the
last couple years it it's been kind of
I've been much better than I was as a
teenager but it's just been I've had
these weird symptoms and so I started
taking colestyramine which is this
binder that you drink it's not
systemically absorbed it just goes into
your gut it binds bile and then
theoretically the toxins that are
circulating around your body that are
recirculated with bile because you don't
necessarily excrete all the bile are
bound up or binded it's probably Bound
by colestyramine and then you poop them
out and that has worked very well but
what really has worked was moving out of
that house I threw away all my clothes
we got rid of all the furniture which
was recommended by the doctors we're
working with I'm working with Dr Scott
McMahon who deals with sers
specifically and then we moved to
Arizona so it took a while to find a
house in Arizona we got it tested
thoroughly made sure there were no leaks
because I'm I'm pretty certain I would
say like 90% sure and hopeful that the
reason I'm allergic to everything is
because a mold exposer as a child and
that I've been using diet and
eliminating all these things from my
diet to mitigate this inflammatory
response that my body's just chronically
in and so hopefully in 6 months or so
I'll be able to tolerate More Foods
because I had one question this is a Q&A
that that's just the update part but I
had one question about whether or not I
think the lion diet is a species
appropriate diet or if it's just used
for people with chronic health issues
and I think anybody with chronic health
issues should try it as an Elimination
Diet to see if diet's playing a role
their symptoms because it certainly was
in mine but I do think that the reason
certain people gravitate towards it is
because they have so much gut damage
that what they're eating is leaking into
their body through their gut and causing
inflammatory responses and I do not
believe that humans didn't evolve to
tolerate like blueberries and carrots
and things so I shouldn't be having
these massive inflammatory responses
with carrots and I always thought the
diet would just heal that and then I was
just stuck on this diet which has been
lifesaving for me and I'm going to
continue it but I would obviously like
to be able to Branch out a bit and just
not have these massive inflammatory
reactions if I introduce a food So
currently I'm still on the line diet um
I'm now eating beef which I didn't do
for a couple years because of histamine
intolerance um so digestive issues with
aged meat that seems to have gone away
but I still can't do things like chicken
without having inflammatory reactions so
like digestive upset pretty much right
away my skin breaks out I get brain fog
for the next couple days I get really
irritable it's not super dramatic like
reintroductions were 5 years ago cuz
I've been on the diet for 5 and a half
years now but still not doable so that's
my update so I spent the last 6 months
working on other things I do so we've
been working very diligently on
launching Peterson Academy which should
be launching at the end of November and
I think we're just going to let about
3,000 people onto the platform and then
work out all the Kinks so if you're one
of the people that signs up
early there might be Kinks on the
platform we're hoping there won't be but
we're going to do the major launch for
New Year's and let anybody come to the
platform anybody in the world is going
to be able to sign up we're going to
have 8 Hour courses taught by just
incredible professors from all over the
world we have quite an array of courses
and we're going to be offering a general
education course with the goal of
teaching people how to think we're not
going to force ideas on people and the
platform looks great I think you can
take notes you can comment you have a
profile so you can communicate with
other students you can form study groups
we're going to enable location so that
if you're in a course and you want to
meet other people taking the course you
can actually meet up in person there's a
lot more that goes into the platform and
once we have all the UI done I'll
probably do an overview on YouTube
running people through the platform but
it'll be easy to use and intuitive so
you won't have to learn it or anything
so I spent a lot of time on that and
then I also managed my dad's brand that
takes up still takes up about 80% of my
time just sorting out problems because
there are always people that are trying
to take advantage of him and so I'm kind
of a wall that says no to that what else
oh and then Fuller Health which credit
to my husband for coming up with that
name but his last name's Fuller my last
name's now Fuller so he was obviously
inclined to go with Fuller Health we're
launching supplements so we started with
a hangover supplement because I've had
real intolerance issues with supplements
otherwise I'd probably be taking them
but I've been able to take this one
supplement called
if you drink I'm not koning drinking
obviously drinking isn't a healthy thing
to do but if you're going to do it and I
do enjoy my vodka sodas and bourbon from
time to time if you are going to do it
you might as well get some help breaking
down the toxic byproduct of alcohol
which reduces hangovers and I've been
using it since I was 20 sourcing it from
like sketchy Chinese websites and now we
have it actually manufactured there are
no fillers there's nothing added they're
just in cellulose C capsules in this
like nice Amber jar hey just to step in
real quick we have launched Afterparty
this is so much better than the sketchy
powder I've been sourcing from China
third party tested the pills are
literally heavy with dihydro myin these
are them you can't tell but they weigh a
ton 30-day money back guarantee free
shipping in the US we just launched 3
days ago give them a shot I swear these
will make you more productive following
drinking they reduce nausea
actually reduce think in the reviews you
can go to Fuller health.com and use code
MP for 15% off and they end up costing
less than $2.40 per avoided hangover
enjoy so I've been working on Fuller
Health Peterson Academy my dad's
brand oh and then you know finding a
house setting up that house moving and I
have a six-year-old so it's been a bit
busy but now that I'm in a house and
we're we're kind of just like living in
a box right now with no furniture but
it's so nice to not be in a hotel now
that I'm
here I have time to podcast again and
put out more content and if you guys are
interested I think I'm going to do more
personal Vlog type content Vlog for lack
of a better word but just more personal
background stuff because I've focused on
podcasting which I love and I get to
learn from people when I'm podcasting
but I haven't gone into a lot of
personal life stuff I think because my
life was such a show for lack of a
better word for so long with uh dad
getting famous and then trying to get a
handle on that and people coming in and
really taking advantage of my family and
then a divorce and it was
just I was like maybe we don't touch
that for now but things are much more
stable now I'm extremely happy in my
relationship I got remarried you guys
know that married somebody somebody
named Jordan which you can all laugh at
I can laugh at too uh and things are
much better now so I'm going to be
putting out a podcast I'm going to try
to go to twice a week I'm going to try
to go to in person and I'm going to be
doing more Vlog stuff so with that
rather lengthy introduction I'm going to
answer some questions okay first to get
the mold out of the way because wow I I
almost never want to talk or say the
word mold again I'm so tired of learning
about mold and what it does to the body
I put together a website it's at
biotoxin dcom which somehow I managed to
snag biotoxin
docomo to get better from mold and
bacteria biotoxins which like I said I
think is is what caused my autoimmunity
so all the information is at biotoxin
doccom I linked a ton of studies there's
studies done from all over the world
linking biotoxin and mold exposure to
things like Alzheimer's and Parkinson's
neurological syndromes Crohn's disease
autoimmunity just terrifying studies and
I wasn't aware of the role I knew the
the environment played a role in health
and I always had air purifiers in my
house been advertising for rabid air for
a while because I know the importance of
air purifiers and keeping things clean
but I didn't realize how little mold
some people's immune systems need need
in order to start this chronic
inflammatory response that they can't
get over so all the information at
biotoxin decom it also links you to
practitioners that can help actual
doctors that are knowledgeable about
this testing you can read all the
studies and you can follow along there
so check out biotoxin
docomo response syndrome was was in my
brain cuz it's complicated on a
biological level it's multi-stem it's
weird all the information is there so if
you think if you have random autoimmune
symptoms or digestive issues or insomnia
brain
fog I would take a look at it and make
sure that's not your problem
because Diet Works like this lion diet
saved my life but if that's the actual
problem underneath things that might be
causing the food sens tivities in the
first place so you need to get a handle
on that so if you're having mold issues
I would say try the lion diet right away
cuz it'll help mitigate symptoms but
then address the root cause by basically
getting out of exposure from mold this
is a good one this is how' your dad
react to meeting the first guy you
brought home to meet him so the first
person I brought home was like a young
teenage like romance just somebody I was
dating going to movies with and things
and that guy told me he loved me and I
told my dad and my dad was
like you should bring him over and I
should meet him so he came over and we
had this incredibly uncomfortable talk
in our living room where we both sat
down and Dad just grilled him about why
do you love my daughter what is it
exactly and so that's how my dad reacted
to the first person I brought home it
was really stressful as like a
14-year-old so that was pretty funny
here's one I'm social my girlfriend is
not we generally stay in and I'd like to
go out more how do I do this
so my dad's got this personality test
you can take it understand.com it's $10
or something ridiculously underpriced in
my opinion uh and you can link other
people to your personality so if you
both take it you can link each other and
then see how you see the areas you might
have issues with in my opinion if
you if you're dating somebody who's
super high in certain personality
aspects so there's openness
conscientiousness extroversion
agreeableness and neuroticism if you
skew way different on extraversion or
conscientiousness or openness I would
say those are the big three there's
definitely going to be issues you have
to figure out like if you're high
conscientious so super organized super
work focused and you're dating someone
who scores really low in those they're
probably going to drive you crazy I
don't even know if those relationships
can work so I'd be careful who you date
based on
conscientiousness um two neurotic people
that might be an issue if one person's
really neurotic and one person's low in
neuroticism I think that can work
because the more stable person can calm
down some of the neuroses and the
neurotic person uh and then for
extroversion I'd
say definitely talk to your significant
other about wanting to go out more and
if she really doesn't want to then you
should do it anyway go out with your
friends and try and fulfill that
extroverted part of yourself with other
things
so doing a podcast for instance for me
I'm very extroverted I scored 98 or 99th
something like that and doing a podcast
really fulfills the extrovert part of me
even if I'm just talking to a camera it
like fills that bucket a little bit um
so I'd go out more with friends and make
sure you're doing it enough otherwise
you're going to get resentful and I
think that relationship's not going to
work out but I would definitely
recommend anybody single or anybody in a
relationship but see what your
personality is and then get other people
to check what theirs is and see if you
guys can work like some of the mistakes
I've made is uh I've gone on dates with
other extroverts who are really low in
conscientiousness and so it's super fun
and then you find out later oh you
really don't have any
drive that's going to be a problem and
that's like an unfixable problem I think
what are some misconceptions about being
divorced SL
remarried one of the misconceptions I
had is I'd listen to a lot of the red
pilled stuff online so I figured okay I
have a kid I'm divorced I'm going to
have a very difficult time finding
somebody because I have all this baggage
and it wasn't just that baggage it's
also um my life's a bit dramatic I work
all the time and I was hoping to find
somebody who would help me with work so
I also needed to look for someone who
was interested in helping me with
working with somebody at home so it was
kind of a tricky Niche to fill I was
either really lucky I think that was
part of it I was really lucky but it
wasn't as difficult as I thought it
would be having a a kid and being
divorced didn't actually hinder men's
interest in me and I've talked to other
women who've been through something
similar where they were divorced and
have a little kid and were very worried
about being devalued and not being able
to be happy again with anyone and they
found it a lot easier too so I would say
if you're in this that situation as a
woman make sure that you're valuable in
in other ways right I mean having a kid
kids are amazing right so if you're
dating someone and they're disgusted at
the fact you have a kid don't go out
with that person and if you're driven
and you're smart and you're capable and
you take care of yourself and all these
other areas of life then that I think
overrides it at least that's my
experience so that was a that was a b
big misconception I had because I
probably stayed in a relationship I
shouldn't have been in for longer
because I
thought if I don't want to be be in this
I have to be prepared to be alone
forever so I kind of had to get to the
point where I was like being alone would
be better I'm okay with that and once I
got to the point where I was okay with
being
alone I wasn't as anxious about it and
things just worked out beautifully okay
breast explant so I haven't talked to
you guys about this but I had a boob
job years ago and I got them I didn't
have it in for very long it was about a
year and a half and I got them taken out
partly because I was so sick from mold I
thought some of the symptoms were coming
from the boob implants
and what I'm going to do is actually a
separate video on plastic surgery that's
not part of this Q&A I'm going to put it
out in the next month so I'll address
that there and I'll just leave it at
that how did you deal with feeling sorry
for yourself when your health was at its
worst so I probably had help from my
parents because I was told at a really
young age like when I got diagnosed with
juvenile rheumatoid arthritis I was in
grade two and my dad told me never use
this as an excuse and so I think growing
up I knew I couldn't exactly feel sorry
for myself and for whatever reason that
included but for whatever reason I
didn't really feel sorry for myself I
was just angry really angry so livid at
not being able to play sports that other
kids could my thumb would get stuck in
the bowling ball cuz I had like really
thickened
joints and I didn't really feel sorry
for myself I was just lividly angry
so is that feeling sorry for
yourself I don't know maybe kind of but
what I would say as someone who's been
chronically
ill for way too long um is that you have
to remember it's not useful it doesn't
actually get you out of the situ
situation so if you're laying in bed
being like why me which is a fair
question when you have an autoimmune
disorder and part of your body is
deciding to die on you you're like oh
why me it self-pity and try to turn it
into anger because anger is more of a
positive emotion you can actually do
something with it like get angry get
frustrated and try to fix it and when
you're that
sick the likelihood that you're going to
go to a doctor and they're going to fix
you from my experience he's zero it just
doesn't work the medical system is
broken so do as much research as you can
and try things and just try them and try
them and try them till they get better
you have to get into the mindset of I
will do anything to get better before I
think you can get better so a lot of the
people that are drawn to the diet I'm on
have tried everything for a very long
time like years and years and at some
point they switch into the mode of of
I'm going to try anything and then they
try the diet because you really have to
get to that point before you're willing
to only eat meat because nobody really
wants to only eat meat I don't know
anyone who's just like I'm going to do
this for fun forever um that being said
I did see this interview with I think
she was an 82-year-old woman on the
carnivore diet by Dr Anthony chaffy I
hope I'm saying that right chaffy who
looked incredible so
she was a farmer and she ate mostly meat
for 65 years and she looks like I would
say like a
55-year-old but she's
82 so I might get her on the podcast cuz
that was pretty impressive but instead
of feeling sorry for yourself get angry
and try and fix the problem and if you
need to spend a day in bed moping about
you can do that from time to time watch
some movies try to get yourself out of
that funk but try to change that into
anger and and fix it cuz I think these
health problems are fixable hey guys
brief Interruption I'd like to introduce
you to carnivore snacks if you don't
already know them these are what my
parents live off of on tour this is what
Scarlet asked for in the mornings these
are so much better than chips they're
worth giving a shot if you want to get
skinny eating chips these are the chips
to eat I like them because they're
literally just beef and salt so they fit
in perfectly with my restrictive diet
but then I've tested them out on my
normal friends too that eat normal
people food and they're hit there too so
there's no additives no seasonings
marinades no sugar just clean meat chips
made in the US they're offering a 15%
discount using code mp15 at checkout
they're Linked In the description at
Carnivor snacks.com that's
snx.com code mp15 at checkout crunchy
goodness and the meat the use is from
regenerative Farms so no
environmentalists can logically come
after you not that they're known for
their logic enjoy the rest of this
episode see here's here's another
question there were a couple questions
like please talk about how you keep your
face so beautiful of course Stakes but
also fillers question mark there's more
to it than fillers which I'm going to
update you guys on now that I'm doing
more personal stuff very soon but the
key thing for me was making sure my diet
was good because dying of autoimmunity
is very unattractive and so that was the
main thing but there are other things
that I will tell tell you guys all about
soon ooh this is fun travel first kids
later or have kids then travel trying to
figure my life out but does one plan
this stuff I don't know if somebody
plans this stuff I always had it in my
head that I wanted to have kids early
and then that happened for
me and I have one my best friend she had
kids when she was
28 which is early compared to the
average person now and I think it's
better to have them early one because
you don't risk as much you don't risk
not being able to have kids which can
really hit women in their mid-30s
sometimes earlier if they're not healthy
and that's a huge risk you don't want to
take and you have a long life to live
and so I think it's better to have kids
sooner even though having kids is really
hard and it does dampen your ability to
do things have kids and travel later
that's what I would do that's what I'm
doing although I'm traveling at the same
time but I'm in
a position that I'm very grateful for
that allows me to do that how has the
family adjusted to the move okay so
there were a couple questions about
Scarlet because she's had such a crazy
life for a six-year-old like she was
with me when we went to Russia with my
dad she was with me in Serbia with my
dad we've probably lived
in a different place every 6 months from
for a number of factors mostly my dad
being sick and US hopping around the
world trying to figure out who could
help
him and she's had lots of different
babysitters because I work so
much and rather than that turning her
into this neurotic child she's actually
really stable she's really stable so I
basically explained the mold situation
and was like you know cuz she got sick
too she had bronchitis almost all the
time every time she get a cold she'd get
bronchitis I was like oh no this is what
used to happen to me as a kid that's no
good she has tree allergies she has all
these allergies even though I've been so
careful with her diet um which I think
is from mold and so she was very excited
when we moved very excited when we got a
new house and we put her in an actin
school and Acton is this type
of education from like I think they do
preschool all the way to grade 12 in
different areas that isn't like the
public system or even the private system
in America I'm a huge fan of it it's not
ideological it teaches kids the Socratic
method they have discussions in class
about what they're grateful for and
she's brought a couple of things home
that I thought okay this is the right
place she's also made she just started
grade one uh a month ago less less uh
two weeks ago she said I have five
friends and I think when we were in
Miami she was at this bougie private
school and the people there
were not my people exactly not that I
have a type of person but I don't think
maybe I do have a type of person um but
she only had two friends that she liked
cuz she said everybody in her class was
kind of bratty and they were we went to
a couple birthday parties and they were
bratty and so the fact that she's made
five friends in two weeks she loves the
school and the school's so different
from her old school the old school
looked like a University campus it had
this huge pool outside I was blown away
it was like this doesn't even exist in
Canada and this new school is in like
the back of a building and cuz it just
started and it's not that big and I was
like wow this is going to be a change
from her bougie private school
and she's she loves it so she's done
really well there hasn't really been a
transition period honestly and I'm
feeling better my husband's feeling
better so the family has adjusted very
well remind us again we can get through
SSRI withdrawal these doctors should be
in
jail so just real quick SSRI withdrawal
does end there are things you can do to
mitigate it it is horrible it is is it's
one of the worst no no no I it's one of
the worst things I've been through other
than watching my dad try to get off of
psych
meds me actually getting off of them
wasn't as bad as watching him because he
had such a harder time it was awful but
it does end it's your brain adapts to
these psych meds and then if you remove
them rapidly your brain's in withdrawal
you've like structurally changed your
brain you can see this on MRIS so if you
go to a doctor and they go oh that
doesn't happen get a new doctor it
happens but that does heal your brain
does heal and a lot of the symptoms can
be mitigated through diet it seriously
changed my life the diet that's why I
went to the lion diet in the first place
was because I was having such terrible
SSRI withdrawal so use diet I would
recommend the lion diet or at least a
ketogenic diet but the ketogenic diet by
itself wasn't good enough for me or my
dad and remember that it seemed seems to
be about 2 years of of healing the first
year is significantly worse than the
second year and you can get through it
100% And when you're through it it'll be
hard to imagine what it even felt like
so stay strong don't suddenly stop
taking ssris or psych meds wean down
very slowly and try to mitigate the side
effects with diet and not everybody gets
these horrible withdrawal syndromes but
people who've been on them at high doses
for a longer period of time or more
prone to them so just stay strong get
through it stay alive it ends things get
better how do you get your folic acid
during pregnancy on Carnivore diets to
avoid neural tube defects okay so I
didn't supplement for a really long time
on the carnivore diet I've been doing it
for 5 and a half years lion diet
specifically and my vitamins were all
good until I moved into that Miami mold
house and then I was trying to see what
was wrong with me and I was like diet
doesn't seem to be helping as much
anymore what's going on and I tested all
my vitamins and they were almost all out
of whack and we tested my dad's vitamins
and his were almost all normal even
though he's been on the diet for the
same amount of time as me so I think it
was mold that did it I started
supplementing folate by injection so
there's a company I'll link it I don't
remember what it's called but I'll just
link it where you can order injectable
folate so if you have a sensitized
immune system that doesn't tolerate oral
folate or folic acid like me you can do
it by
injection anybody who's doing any type
of diet or even any random person who's
not doing a diet I would recommend doing
vitamin testing and making sure that's
all good and supplementing when you're
not so just how to get your folic acid
during pregnancy I would just out of an
abundance of caution supplement now a
lot of people will be like oh eat more
liver and do these things but you want
to take folate deficiency seriously so
I'd supplement and I'm supplementing
with injectable folate cuz my folate was
very low and it's hard to say what
caused
that I'm sure part of it was mold and
who knows maybe part of it was being on
the diet for five and a half years but I
just for anyone because these things are
so new for anyone doing any type of diet
monitor them monitor the vitamins and
supplement just make sure you don't
react to the supplements and if you do
try to find the injectable ones and
those work for anything that's not fat
soluble for the fat soluble ones you
actually need to inject them into a
muscle and so then I go in somewhere and
get them
injected how was pierce off camera so I
did Pierce Morgan which was fun because
you get to go to a studio and get like
dressed up and it's a studio so that's
fun he was super
polite and nice there wasn't a lot a lot
more to that he was super polite and
nice to me so that was really fun I was
very grateful to be on there biggest
motivator to stay
disciplined my biggest motivator to stay
disciplined is to really Envision what I
want so say for working on Peterson
Academy and pushing that forward I'm you
know visualizing the platform and what
that looks like and then just working
towards that so I think if you're not
motivated you probably don't have a well
visualized end goal so really think
about what your end goal is whether
that's for health say you want to get
fit like picture yourself like that and
then just keep working towards it or if
you have some sort of autoimmune
disorder or chronic disease really try
to believe you can get better CU I
believe you can get better I don't think
bodies are just made to be broken
they're reacting to something and you
have to figure out what that something
is whether it's the environment you know
like issues from from mold or from
growing up around mold when you were a
kid leaky gut from what you're eating or
from too many antibiotics as a kid
addressing all those things just picture
yourself healthy believe that like I I
don't believe in manifesting I'm not a
manifester person but having a goal a
well visualized goal really helps with
motivation you have to really want it
you're not going to be motivated to do
something unless you really want it and
if you're working work on something you
don't really want you should probably
find something else to work on what do
you think about functional medicine
anybody who needs a doctor I would say
go to a functional doctor functional
medicine doctor they're going to have
experience from the more mainstream
medical side and they're going to look
at what natural paths are looking at so
I'd say functional doctor is the way you
want to go if you need a doctor piece of
advice you'd give your younger self so a
couple one
stop eating garbage it's impacting you
way more than you think it's impacting
your ability to sleep it's giving you
chronic fatigue it's making you
depressed it's changing your reality
like it's making you gain
weight stop eating foods that are bad
for you which means processed foods in
general and probably grains and dairy
that would be my number one piece of
advice my second piece of advice would
be if you're trying really hard at
something and it's not working out and
it feels like everything you're doing
isn't
working maybe it's not working right
maybe those are Universal signs signs
from God that this isn't the path you
should be taking and I guess the third
piece of advice would be if you're
having a really hard time have faith
that you can get through it and that
it's going to end and that that
difficult time is going to teach you
something that so valuable that the
difficult time will be worth going
through now when bad things happened so
when I got quite ill from mold and was
it was scary uh because I didn't have an
internal dialogue and I started to
literally not be able to think enough to
answer emails in my inbox which is scary
I was too weak to go upstairs in Miami
which was crazy so Jordan was helping me
go upstairs and I was like I have no
energy in any of my muscles it feels
like I've been working out but I haven't
been working out when when that kind of
thing happens to me cuz bad things are
going to happen even if you have your
life organized have faith that you've
gotten through bad things before you can
get through this one that things will
get better and that this is just a
period of almost think about it like a
test that's what I do now is I go okay
there's something here that I need to
learn and I believe that so there's
something here that I need to learn I
really hope it doesn't take me 2 years
to learn it I hope this is more of a 3
to six month process
and that you'll come out on the other
side wiser and stronger maybe humbler so
yes those are my three pieces of advice
what's your skinc care regimen okay so
I'm going to just stick this in the
Plastic Surgery episode uh because
there's lasers involved and there's a
lot of things involved uh my main
skincare regimen was fixing my diet
because my skin was a mess before diet I
really mean a mess and diet basically
fixed it I wasn't using any skincare
products was glowing then I moved back
into the Miami house and like my skin
died again even though my diet was the
same it was very
frustrating uh I tried to reintroduce
chicken last week cuz I didn't want to
eat steak anymore and then my skin broke
out that was last week so I diet's huge
uh if you can get rid of grains and
dairy and processed foods and eat Whole
Foods and if you're just a regular
person that doesn't have any serious
autoimmunity or or depression or
insomnia major symptoms
Max luga is a really good guy to follow
he kind of teaches what people should
eat like um and I'm kind of torn at the
moment whether or not I believe what Max
says I think his nutritional information
is very solid for the average healthy
person or if you're interested I'd go
more animal-based where you're primarily
eating meat but then you have these
other nonprocessed foods to eat that can
really help your skin and then I'll talk
about all the other things
soon o what are your thoughts on
blueprint from Brian Johnson okay so you
guys probably have heard of Brian
Johnson but he's this Tech entrepreneur
guy super smart and he's put millions of
dollars into Rejuvenation and anti-aging
and he's on a vegan diet he does like
lasers all the time red light therapy he
has Biometrics of almost everything in
his entire body which is really cool
that's something I would have really
liked to do but I didn't have the money
to be able to measure or everything but
I think following him is very
interesting I don't agree with the vegan
approach I think most of the research
done on diet and the longevity research
done on diet is done on vegan diets and
calorie restriction and fasting and I
think there's really something to
calorie restriction and fasting but I
think this high protein leading to
health issues is incorrect and I know
there's there's somebody else who
H you you guys will know him there's
another longevity guy that that says he
people should use a vegan diet and I
don't think that is scientifically
accurate or up toate so other than that
but he's going based off of scientific
papers so I can see how he got there
other than that I think he's a very
interesting human being I was actually
supposed to interview him in January and
I cancelled twice because I couldn't
think my internet wasn't working because
because I couldn't think really uh no
that was actually by chance that was
because of a storm in Miami but I would
like to interview him I think he's very
interesting best and worst thing about
being newly married so I've almost been
married for 2 years now to
Jordan and the best thing is I don't
feel lonely anymore and I was so lonely
uh even though I was okay with being
alone I was so lonely and I'm not lonely
anymore so that's one of the best things
um and that isn't like a position that
anybody could fill I couldn't just get
married to someone and not be lonely cuz
you can certainly be lonely in a
relationship so uh that's cuz I found
the right person but that's probably the
best part and the worst part I think
because we got married so quickly the
scariest part for me has been did we get
married too quickly do I even know this
person well enough
um and sometimes I can get some like
existential angst of
the world kind of feels like it's
falling on me and is anything I believe
real I don't know if you guys get that
but I certainly get that sometimes and
that's me being existential and so
that's been I guess the worst thing is
me second guessing myself but I'm I'm
pretty positive this is this was the
right decision
so there haven't really been bad things
about it it's basically just been good
this is a tricky one unplanned pregnancy
and deciding whether you should be with
the partner after that
so I had an unplanned
pregnancy when I was 24 Skarlet
and I probably should have
not stayed with um that person I think
it would have been better for everybody
including Scarlet but at the time I
thought that if you had an unplanned
pregnancy it would be better to have a
stable family and just be with that
person I think it's really dependent on
the situation so if you can make it work
if you can figure out any way to make it
work you should try as hard as you can
to make it work even if you don't know
that person very well like try as hard
as you can to make it work if it really
doesn't work then I don't think it's
better for a family to stay together
um if if everybody's
miserable why would anyone want to grow
up in a miserable household so I can't
help more than that um I think you
should be supportive regardless through
the pregnancy and present and then
honest with the other person about
talking about how your future could look
there is a very complicated situation
and ideally this is also why Christians
and people who are religious say don't
have sex before you get married because
the ramifications of an unplanned
pregnancy are you're impacting another
person's life
that isn't
yours you know and you're all tied up in
this unplanned pregnancy and it's a mess
or it can be a mess sometimes it can
just be a blessing but sometimes it can
be a mess and so I can understand why
people say don't have sex before
marriage um but I think it's very
dependent on the person if you can make
it work try to make it work if it's
really not working don't just force this
resentful family on a little kid I don't
think that's better for them than having
two separated people that are happy with
different families what would you do if
you found out your husband was sleeping
with a trans
woman get a second
divorce it's not even there's nothing to
think about there don't even delve into
the wise there be like oh okay bye what
do you think about OIC maybe I'll stick
this into that other video about plastic
surgery that I'm going to do I don't
know a ton about AIC I think way weight
loss is healthy for people I think there
are other ways you can do it like the
keto diet works so well for weight loss
that I do the keto diet first I think
OIC should be left to people who aren't
honestly disciplined enough to do a keto
diet um because I think you should
tackle it from that
ankle but if you're not disciplined
enough to do the keto diet and you do
want to lose weight and you're really
overweight ozempic might be worth a shot
I saw some studies on heart issues and
it's pretty new and you want to be
careful about injecting or taking
anything new that doesn't have a lot of
research on it so be
careful be careful with that one and
just honestly have some self-discipline
and go the diet route but being
extremely obese is very unhealthy so I
would assume
the I would assume it would be better to
take OIC and not be obese than it would
be to do nothing and stay obese
but use diet instead if you can do that
have you looked into highd does IV stem
cells for autoimmunity I have I plan on
doing them I'm going to have Dr Khan
back on my podcast I did a podcast with
him like right before I kind of died in
Miami uh and we talked about stem cells
and ooh and NK natural killer cell
infusions I'm definitely going to look
into those um Mom and Dad actually had
stem cell infusions recently I don't
know if they've noticed anything yet
but seems super promising I don't think
it's this cure but maybe it is I'm going
to try it out anyway but I mean seems
unlikely that you can just keep living
your life the way you're living it
eating whatever you want and take IV
stem cells and just be fine I think you
have to tackle Health from way more
angles than that how can I meet people
for dating who understand my crazy diet
yeah so I kind of I'm doing too many
things right now
but I like doing too many things or I
get bored and I like being able to hop
from Project to project so I'm like okay
finished my inbox finished everything on
Dad's side let's do a bit on PA how's
Fuller Health going want stick a podcast
in there um I kind of want to put out a
dating app and this biohacker named
Melanie
Avalon is interested in doing it too
I've been talking about a dating app for
people who are on the paleo diet or keto
diet or carnivore diet for a long time
we could potentially incorporate dad's
personality test in there and then you
could join it even if you're not on a
diet you could say I'm not on a diet so
that's not a factor but you could figure
out your personality so that can show up
on your profile so you can be linked to
other people with similar personalities
that that mesh or personalities that
mesh they don't have to be similar in
all the different traits that kind of
sounds like a fun side project if we're
going to pursue that so I'll keep you
guys posted but you can tell me if you
think that would be useful but I know
especially if you're on one of these
crazy like keto diets or vegans aren't
allowed on the platform though sorry
guys I'm not doing plant-based on it but
if you're on a keto or a carnivore diet
it is pretty hard to date without
finding other like-minded people it just
makes you kind of into a weirdo so okay
a bunch of people asked about Scarlet is
she on the lion diet how's she doing is
it okay to put kids on the lion diet and
Scarlet's not on the lion diet she's on
an animal-based diet so she E's a ton of
meat but she eats like fish and chicken
and mostly beef and then she eats
certain
fruit um a little bit of vegetables and
she's I mean she's doing very well she
gets stomach aches like one of the mold
symptoms she had was stomach aches and
kind of urgency issues running to the
bathroom and then bronchitis all the
time and I'm hoping that with mold
treatment she won't get stomach aches as
much so we'll be able to expand or Diet
more the only reason that it's as
restrictive as it is although I would
never introduce processed foods and
sugar back in um I'm debating whether or
not we want to give raw milk a shot
because I've heard mixed things about
that I just don't want anything to go
badly but I think she'll be able to
tolerate more things in about maybe even
sooner than 6 months maybe like 3 months
so we'll try and expand out but for kids
on the lion diet if your kid has an
autoimmune disorder so like kids get
diagnosed with juvenile rheumatoid
arthritis when they're too
if that's happening I think the dangers
of that getting worse and multiple joint
Replacements and like a crippling
disease forever people with autoimmunity
also die sooner it's really bad that
compared to a diet that might most
people are worried it'll make them into
a like a weird kid I don't think Kids
Care like Scarlet hasn't been bothered
at all I've taught her hey like a lot of
people eat pizza and a lot of people eat
lollipops and candy and they don't
really know how bad that is for them but
that's bad for them she has these little
fruit snacks they're still in not
plastic but probably plastic that you
undo but it's just pure fruit so she has
these snacks that she can eat other kids
like them too she eats jerky she doesn't
feel weird or restricted she just thinks
she's eating healthy so I think if if
your kid is really sick I would put them
on Elimination Diet right away Scarlet's
been Scarlet was basically on a line
diet for the first three years of her
life before we started reintroducing
Foods we reintroduced some foods a
little bit earlier than that it's
obviously something you can do long term
I don't think it's necessary for
children I think it's a good way to
reintroduce food or to introduce Foods
in the first place to start a baby off
on meat and then introduce a food one at
a time and monitor for like eczema and
stomach aches and all these things um
and I think it's way safer than having a
kid with autoimmunity and letting them
eat whatever they want so it's going to
depend on
you as a parent and what you want to do
but I know uh we did food sensitivity
testing when I was in grade two after I
got diagnosed with arthritis and
everything showed up in red except for
meat and it was really bad it was like
oh your body's reacting to everything
and my dad said well we can't first of
all that's ridiculous that can't
possibly be true and second of all uh
she's going to be an outcast at school
what is she going to do at birthday
parties and it would have been in my
best interest to just put me on all me
right away
because like having my ankle and hip
replaced when I was 17 made me into an
outcast more than having a restricted
diet would have so depends on how sick
your kid is I hope your kid isn't sick
but it's not that big a deal to put your
kid on an Elimination Diet it's not it
might feel like one but it's not they
might squawk for a couple days cuz they
miss sugar but they'll get over it in a
couple days kids love meat generally
speaking so try it out out for 6 weeks
see if you can figure out the symptoms
and then reintroduce Foods back in don't
think about it as this lifelong thing
like me being on it for five and a half
years uh I feel like if people had
started it if I had started it earlier
then I wouldn't be in this kind of
situation although who knows what role
mold was playing in that so that's my
Q&A I will see you next week on a
podcast about narcissism that is great I
think I learned a lot not that I was
great but the guy was talk to was
great and I will do another Q&A in about
3 weeks
specifically H it's going to be more of
a like a info video on plastic surgery
so see you then thanks for hanging
around and waiting for me to recover
from mold and I'm very glad to be
[Music]
back